- [Narrator] Thanks to hover
for keeping legal eagle in the air.
Get 10% off your first domain.
Using the link in the description.
Warning! Video contains graphic images
of fake blood, real insects
and terrifying lawyering.
Viewer discretion is advised.
- [McKamey] You don't need
to read it. Just sign it.
It says I can physically abuse you.
- What?
- I'm here to hurt you.
- I can't do it. I can't do it.
I can't do it.
- That's not good
- I wanna (indistinct)
- Help.
- Hmmm.
(soft music)
- Happy Halloween legal eagles.
Today we're taking a look at
one of America's most
notorious scary attractions.
This is a haunt where visitors may
have their heads forcibly shaved,
be submerged in a tank full of water
or wind up strapped down
while bugs crawl into their mouths.
It's a haunt so terrifying.
So spine tingling
and so bloody that it inspired
a change.org petition asking
for it to be outlawed.
Yes, I'm talking about
the Internet's favorite,
McKamey Manor.
That controversial fright attraction
where you have to sign
a very very long waiver
while wearing an adult onesie
just to get the chance to suffer
through a multi-day experience
that could end with you winning $20,000
- Do not come here.
- And I can't tell you how many times
people have emailed me asking.
"Is it real?"
"And is it legal?"
The attractions founder Russ McKamey,
has created a house of horrors
that has bedeviled the Hans community.
Is McKamey for real?
Does he really get people
to legally consent to being tortured?
Or is he just an amazing show man,
who creates videos that make it look like
he runs some kind of
summer camp for sadists?
Let's take a break from the horrors
of the political world
to discuss the real horror show
and its legality in McKamey Manor.
(upbeat music)
So what is the McKamey Manor experience?
You could say that McKamey
Manor is similar to
the thousands of other
frightening attractions
that have operated during
the Halloween season,
but you'd be wrong.
McKamey Manor is not a haunted house.
They claim it's an experience
that lasts anywhere from
four hours to three days,
where participants are
exposed to extreme physical
and mental assaults in secret locations.
If this sounds like your
kinds of thing, well,
you can't just buy a ticket.
Russ McKamey says that
there's a waiting list
of more than 20,000 people
who are begging to be at his mercy.
What happens during your
stay at McKamey Manor?
Well you'll be exposed to extreme acts
like being kidnapped and then forced
through a series of physical challenges.
People have been put in a straitjacket
and dumped in a tank of eels
and force fed while tied up.
Participants may find
themselves strapped to a bed
where snakes crawl over their bodies.
McKamey Manor's YouTube
channel is full of clips
and photos of people shivering
in fear and covered in
dirt and fake blood.
Well, at least we hope it's fake.
McKamey films all of this
and retains the footage.
And unlike other haunt experiences
where participants use skill
and acting to scare you
without touching you,
McKamey Manor employees
go out of their way
to touch you.
Of course the McKamey website
hasn't been updated for the COVID-19 era.
So actually any kind of physical touching
seems kind of nice at this point.
Mmmh.
Oh.
But until recently, McKamey Manor
didn't even use a safe word
to make the experience stop.
And the waiver explicitly says
you aren't allowed to fight back.
So when does it end?
Well, when Russ McKamey decides
that you are mentally
or physically broken.
- [McKamey] So legally are you
saying that's it, you quit?
- Yeah.
- [McKamey] Is that cool?
- I mean I don't want
to disappoint, but yeah.
- This year the attraction
begins in Sumiton, Alabama.
Which is 45 minutes over the Alabama line.
And if you make it
through your experience,
which is hosted by a terrifying woman
who will sap you of your will to live.
Then you're officially taken to Nashville
to an attraction called Caedis Silvis,
which is Latin for murder in the woods.
But McKamey says no one
has made it past murder in the woods yet.
McKamey's Sumiton neighbors are alarmed.
They've reported hearing chainsaws
and screams coming from
the barn all night long.
One neighbor said they had
a girl pulling out down
one of the driveways over there.
They had a girl by the neck
pulling her with a chain.
McMamey said this was just
an actor filming a bit for him.
McKamey insist that his attractions
are a labor of love
and he just loves a good scare.
He claims that during the entry interview,
he learns about people's fears
and then designs the experience to create
psychological terror.
If you buy the hype behind the waiver
and all of the videos McKamey has posted
to his YouTube channel,
then it looks as if McKamey
isn't trying to scare people.
He's trying to torture them.
And the scenes look straight
out of horror movies
like Hostile.
- I just wanna go home to my grand mummy
and my daughter, my husband.
Please.
- So the question is,
how can this be legal?
Well, we start with the extremely
long waiver that participants
are forced to sign.
According to news reports,
neighbors have called
the police when they hear
or see something scary
at the McKamey place.
But police don't file charges
because the participants signed a waiver.
A waiver, as you probably know,
is an agreement that offers a business
two protections.
First, the waiver relieves one party
of any blame or liability
arising from negligence
or wrong-doing regarding
the particular activity,
such as running through
a bunker's haunted house.
Second. One party, usually the one
that drafted the agreement,
is freed from all liability arising
out of the performance of that contract.
Now, if you've ever
interacted in the real world,
you know that you can
find liability waivers
and disclaimers almost anywhere.
Like a dry cleaner receipt
prohibiting the dry cleaner
from liability for damage to the clothing.
Or a normal amusement park
that doesn't torture its patrons,
you can find a waiver on the ticket.
Or signs such as swim at your own risk
or park at your own risk.
From a public policy perspective,
it's considered positive to let
private parties regulate their own affairs
and allocate risk.
However the law also won't let parties
be completely reckless.
Especially when there's
unequal bargaining power.
Since courts have to balance
all of these factors,
anyone running a recreational
or event based business,
needs a waiver that satisfies
specific conditions.
So let's talk about
some of those conditions
which includes that a
waiver must be voluntary.
A waiver is a contract
or an addendum to a contract.
And for that contract to be valid,
the parties have to demonstrate
that they voluntarily entered into it.
This means that the person entered
into it freely without
coercion or interference,
and that the person had the knowledge
and capacity to act.
Now there's no evidence
that McKamey lets minors
or people with diminished capacity
go through the manner.
But the bigger question is
whether people are voluntarily
signing that waiver.
In Schneckloth versus Bustamonte,
the Supreme court stated that
a waiver is not valid if quote,
coerced by explicit or implicit means,
by implied threat or covert force.
And before McKamey will
agree to take someone
through this creation,
they have to sit down with him
and discuss what may happen
during the experience.
Participants are asked to
sign a 30 to 40 page waiver
limiting McKamey's liability
for anything that happens.
They watch a two hour video showing
what other people
experienced in McKamey Manor.
And participants must
produce notes from a doctor
proving that they are in great physical
and mental health.
- [McKamey] Did you get
your medical mental letter
saying you are okay?
- Yep.
- [McKamey] All right
make sure you bring that.
- There'll be a drug test
and participants have to prove
that they have health insurance.
And McKinney also insists
that participants bring a friend.
So together you and a friend
will wear adult onesies,
while McKamey explains
how he intends to drown
you and rough you up
while begging you not
to go through with it.
- [McKamey] You really
don't want to do this.
- So are people who enter McKamey Manor
signing their waiver freely
without interference?
Well McKamey stresses his
rigorous screening process.
But his promotional videos
show us something else.
That people are allegedly tortured
while they sign the paperwork.
- [McKamey] We're gonna
sign some paperwork now.
I'll give you some waivers, all of you.
- And many people on the internet claim
that the participants are kidnapped
and tortured before
they ever sign a waiver.
So how do we prove that
this is true though?
Well, as far as I can tell,
he hasn't been sued by
anyone claiming this.
And frankly in America,
the fact that you haven't been sued
over something is not bad evidence
that you actually didn't engage
in the actual activity itself.
(eagle screeching)
But the videos McKamey Manor uploads
to the YouTube channel purport to show
that people are being slapped around
and forced to sign paperwork.
But there's also what
happens to be some skillful
slight of hand here.
The video purports to
show a woman named Beth,
going over some paperwork
while bloodied, bruised and restrained.
- [McKamey] When you're
screaming for mercy and crying
and you want out,
do you want me to let you go?
- No sir.
- [McKamey] Say it louder?
- But if you look closely, you can see
that the actor put fake
blood capsules in her mouth
and then she spits out the fake blood.
This is of course looks
atrocious and terrible.
But in this video you'll see
that people are being
asked to sign waivers
in the middle of the experience
- [McKamey] Read 20 together. Go.
- Participants fully
understand and agrees that
no ones (indistinct)
- If it happened before the experience,
this could be coercion.
- [McKamey] Don't get
the papers wet gentlemen,
they need to sign.
- The video is edited to show participants
including Beth being slapped
around while they look at the waiver.
But then the video cuts to a time
when Beth is agreeing on camera
that she has read and
agreed to the waiver.
- [McKamey] Did you
freely sign the waiver?
And did you really understand
what you're reading?
And did we read it out loud?
Like a little three-year-old
and go through it page by page?
(laughs)
- Yes we did.
It was a process, but we did it.
- Here McKamey tells her
that she won't be injured or killed,
but may end up with bumps and bruises
and even a broken bone.
- [McKamey] You know that
no ones gonna kill you.
- Yeah.
- [McKamey] You know that
you're not gonna get injured.
But you also know that you're very likely,
in fact, I can guarantee you
that you're going to get bumps
and bruises and sprains,
maybe even a broken bone.
- Russ should probably
know that bumps and bruises
and broken bones are in fact injuries,
but we'll leave that aside for the moment.
- [McKamey] There's some
bruises (indistinct)
That's what you get.
(laughs)
[McKamey] Man, it looks good.
- And he had Beth agrees on camera
before she even starts the event.
- [McKamey] We never had a broken bone,
but maybe you're the first, right?
- Maybe I'll be the record breaker.
- [McKamey] (indistinct)
the actual real breaker.
- Did she sign the waiver then to?
McKamey implies that she did.
We know he has a video
of him reading the various
parts of this waiver.
And it's also possible
that these are just actors (laughs).
And it's just really
really good marketing.
But later in the same video,
McKamey interviews Beth
after the events depicted in the video
asking did we ever force you
to which she replies absolutely not.
- [McKamey] And you know
that it's physical forehand.
You know, all these things, right?
So do we keep any secrets from you -
- Absolutely not.
- Without telling you?
- But is this truly a situation
where Beth feels that she has no choice
but to sign the contract?
Is she being compelled by force?
And then the threat of force.
We don't really know for sure,
because the video cuts to a clip
of Beth before she enters the
event where she's pretty obviously capable
of signing the waiver.
And here's Beth later saying that yes
she went through page by page.
- It was a process but we did it.
- According to Beth,
she signed the paperwork
before the experience and
acquiesced to it ahead of time.
And obviously if people
didn't sign the waiver ahead of time
and aren't informed about
what's about to happen.
Then yes, McKamey might
have all sorts of liability.
So if McKamey beat them
or held them at gunpoint
or use some sort of economic coercion
against them when they sign the waiver,
then I'm confident the waiver
would probably be invalid. (laughs)
But you can look at this
specific video and conclude
that the actors probably
make the participants go
through the whole waiver process
again during the experience
for the show of it
as part of the psychological
game that they play
or they were just making the
actors sign fake waivers.
But let's talk about another one
of the requirements for this
crazy waiver to be valid.
Which is that a waiver must be specific
about known and unknown risks.
All States have their own requirements
when it comes to these sort of things.
But whether a waiver will be enforceable,
generally boils down to whether the injury
arises from risks stated in the waiver.
This means that the language of the waiver
should be specific about
both known and unknown risks
and the inherent risks of an activity.
Starting with paragraph 17,
the McKamey Manor waiver
starts listing all
of the things that could happen
to someone who participates
in McKamey Manor.
There could be bumps, bruises cuts
and other possible injuries,
including broken bones.
Paragraph 18 asks that you
not fight with the actors.
Well 19 warns that
with respect to doing
the entire experience,
you really don't want
to do this, in all caps.
Paragraph 24 says that you understand
you aren't being held against your will.
And McKamey Manor is well aware
that the neighbors may
misconstrue what's going on
and call the police.
That's why paragraph three
says the participant agrees
that if the police are called
or appear on the scene,
that participant acknowledges
that this is just a game.
This idea that this is just a game
is a common theme in this crazy contract.
What else is in this contract?
Forcibly shaved head and eyebrows.
There's a paragraph for that.
Stuffed inside a 55 gallon drum
and rolled down a hill onto a pond,
count on it.
Buried in a pit with
hundreds of mice, rats
and rodents.
Your responsibility to fight through it.
Knives in close contact with your body,
even your neck.
Definitely possible.
Hypothermia.
Sure. Why not?
Hundreds of welts from a paintball gun.
Obviously.
Now in a stroke of genius,
some of these scenarios are
probably just there to get
inside your head, to
play on your worst fears
like Russ McKamey promises.
This would be the bits
about being buried alive.
Submerged in 60 feet of water
without a breathing apparatus.
Walking a plank 25 feet off the ground
without a safety net.
Encountering poisonous animals
or possible electrocution.
This all sounds ridiculous
but McKamey claims that
he's never been sued.
But he also claims that he has been sued.
And then all lawsuits have been thrown
out once he reveals the
videos of what happened.
So we're dealing with some
inconsistent information.
But is this waiver good in a court of law?
Well that requires digging
into something called a
pre-injury release waiver.
McKamey Manor's waiver is
such a pre-injury release.
This is a written document
that a participant signs
before engaging in a
recreational activity.
The document is a contract which
releases the service provider from claims
and individual may bring as a result
of the providers negligence.
You typically sign a pre-injury release
for skydiving, bungee
jumping and trampoline parks.
This release feature liability
is a contractual agreement
where one party surrenders legal rights
or obligations.
Though generally a valid release
continues to be a complete bar to recovery
and negligence actions in
almost every jurisdiction.
But what courts consider
to be a valid release
varies from state to state.
Here's an example of the most recent
McKamey Manor waiver.
Is from 2017,
the jurisdiction is California.
So for purposes of this video
I'll discuss California, Tennessee
and Alabama law together.
Since pre-injury releases
are valid and enforceable
in all three States under
generally similar circles.
Though generally a waiver is unenforceable
if there's fraud or willful injury.
Now you might be thinking,
but isn't that exactly
what McKamey Manor is doing?
Intentionally causing injury.
Well not so fast
because the contractual language goes
into explicit detail about the harm
that may be for you.
But always with the caveat
that this is the type
of harm that would be an accident
and is no way intentionally
or most importantly willful.
The waiver requires participants to agree
that their lives are not in danger
and it's just a game.
Participants are supposed to realize
that they aren't really being tortured
even if it feels like they are.
It says that you'll be roughed up
but no one is there to actually hurt you.
This is McKameys's way of saying that
an injury is accidental and not willful.
But then there's the issue of negligence.
And whether you can
wave a negligence claim.
The legal system defines negligence
as the failure to exercise
the care towards others
which are reasonable or
prudent person would do
in the same or similar circumstances.
And to prove negligence
lawyers have to show
that a person being sued
had a duty of care to another person.
That they breached that duty
and that the breach caused
the plaintiff's injuries
By waiving negligence claims,
people who participate in McKamey Manor
are giving up their right to sue
if McCainy acts unreasonably.
But can someone simply waive claims
of ordinary negligence?
Well, yes, almost always you can.
Unless the process of
getting the waiver signed
was somehow fraudulent
or the person who signed
the release was a minor.
The parties can waive their
right to sue for negligence.
As long as the waiver accurately
expresses the intent of the parties
and the injuries reasonably
included in the type
of thing that the waiver
was intended to cover,
that negligence waiver
will probably be upheld.
People who've tried to sue
haunted attractions for negligence
have been kicked out of court
because they waived
their negligence claims.
For example, in 2011, Scott Griffin
and friends went to the
Haunted Trail in San Diego.
The haunted trail was a mile long path
where visitors were chased by actors
dressed in scary costumes,
carrying fake weapons.
And the tickets that they purchased
had a warning that said
the trail included quote
high impact scares.
Griffin and his friends
made it through the
trail with no problems.
But as they walked out to the exit,
an actor carrying a revving chainsaw
rushed towards them.
Griffin made what some
would call a rookie mistake,
thinking that the attraction was over
before he was back in his car.
He panicked and fell injuring both wrists,
which were in cast for four months.
The court dismissed the negligence lawsuit
because of the ticket disclaimer.
Quote, being chased within
the physical confines
of the Haunted Trail by a
chainsaw carrying maniac
is a fundamental part
and inherent risk of this amusement.
Griffin voluntarily paid
money to experience it.
As the Griffin case demonstrates,
a plaintiff goes through
a Halloween attraction
for the purpose of being scared.
- You scared me dog.
- That's the point, is it?
- It is, it is and you're doing well
- As long as the person
is sufficiently warned
about the potential hazards prior
to entering a certain space,
courts probably won't
hold the business liable
for injuries caused by mistakes
the business makes.
Or the injuries that might result
from fear-based reactions.
And for an example of basic negligence,
consider the case of Mays
versus Gretna Athletic Boosters.
There, a Louisiana business
got sued for using a lot
of black visqueen material
inside of the haunted house.
A ten-year-old girl got frightened
and ran straight into a cinder block wall,
breaking her nose.
Now, even if the business
arguably made the haunted house too dark,
so dark that she couldn't tell
it was a cinder block wall.
The negligence waiver was upheld.
That's because the business
didn't intend for this to happen.
It may have made a mistake
but generally the building's construction
were sound.
Haunted house operators
are duty bound to protect patrons
only from unreasonably
dangerous conditions
and probably not from
every conceivable danger.
Another example of a fear-based reaction
happened in Louisiana.
Where the plaintiff broke her leg
in a corn maze while running from an actor
dressed as Jason from Friday the 13th.
The court ruled that she
was explicitly warned
that she might be chased
by scaring looking actors.
Quote we find that no duty was owed
by the Billingses to Mrs.Durmon
in this case to warn or protect her
from her reaction to being frightened
by Jason,
an experience she expected to have
and for which he paid an
additional admission fee.
But there is an exception to this rule
and that's for gross negligence
and recklessness.
Such a contractual waiver
won't protect McKamey Manor if it's guilty
of what's called gross negligence.
What is gross negligence?
And how is it different
from regular negligence?
Well, gross negligence
generally involves a higher
degree of bad conduct
and callous indifference to consequences.
In Tennessee, where McKamey now lives,
the law doesn't let people contract
away liability for gross negligence.
However, it's often hard to prove
that someone committed gross negligence.
You'd have to prove one,
that the person committed
ordinary negligence.
And two, the person acted
with utter unconcern
for the safety of others
or with such a reckless disregard
for the rights of others.
The conscious indifference to
the consequences is implied.
A good example of gross
negligence occurred in Kentucky
where Glenda Dickson broke her back
in four places after falling
out of a second story window
in a haunted house.
Dickson signed a waiver
and knew that the house would be scary.
However, when she was near
a second story open window,
one of the actors ran behind Dickson
and her group screaming
causing everyone to jump in terror
Dickson jumped backwards
and fell out of the open window.
The window was covered by a sheet
and Dickson had no idea
it was actually open.
In this case there was
ordinary negligence.
An actor scaring a person
near an open window
causes reckless disregard
for what may happen to others
as a result of the negligence.
And a reasonable haunted house
would have shut the window
that was covered with a sheet
before scaring someone who stood
near it to prevent defenestration.
So even though some people are horrified
by the footage of McKamey Manor,
it'd be hard to argue that McKamey
was being misleading
or failing to warn them
about the hazards that they might face.
Now there's one final
question about McKamey Manor.
And it's probably the question you've had
throughout this entire video.
Which is, can a person actually
consent to legitimately harmful acts
being perpetrated against them?
And a person on (indistinct)
whether it was legal for
McKamey Manor to kill a person.
And the answer to that is no.
If someone died during the experience,
then it would be possible
that their family would have a valid
legal claim against McKamey
Manor for wrongful death.
Even if they sign the
waiver without coercion.
Unless the death resulted
from very ordinary negligence.
Let's say someone died from hypothermia.
The waiver warns that
hypothermia is a risk
but it also says if
hypothermia is detected
the person will be pulled out immediately.
If McKamey Manor failed to
detect it and someone died
their estate might be able
to sue for gross negligence.
And not all deaths would lead to a claim.
If someone signed the waiver
and produced documents
saying that they were
in good health and they
actually had a heart problem
and that person had a heart attack,
McKamey Manor wouldn't
necessarily be liable.
It depends heavily on the facts.
- They're just asking to have someone die
or have a heart attack.
What happens if someone
dies during their tour?
It waver won't mean anything.
We have had one heart attack for real.
Seven years ago, we had a heart attack.
That was good stuff.
- And the most common question
people have about McKamey Manor
is whether it's legal
for someone to consent
to being hurt maimed or even
killed at a fright attraction.
And unsurprisingly,
the answer is both no and yes.
In most jurisdictions,
consent is a defense to
crimes that don't result
in serious injury or happen
during sporting events.
So if we're talking about serious injury,
no McKamey Manor can't
intentionally kill someone
or cause them egregious bodily harm
even if they sign the waiver.
It isn't legal for McKamey Manor
to let participants
drown or freeze to death
no matter what the waiver says.
That's against public policy.
So now, you know, the general rule,
consent cannot be given a
serious harmful criminal act.
But as with most things in the law,
there are some exceptions.
A person generally is allowed
to consent to serious harm
if the harm is for the purposes of
medical treatment like amputating a leg.
They could also consent
to being punched or kicked
or even attacked as long as they are
in a legally sanctioned event
such as boxing or mixed martial art.
And this is legal
even though these events could result
in serious harm or even death.
Boxers have been killed in the ring.
But the participants and the promoters
generally don't have
a legal responsibility
for murder or manslaughter
that might happen in a boxing ring.
Boxing is a state regulated activity
that's lawful unless the death happens
because of something
unrelated to the fight.
Like the roof collapsing in the ring.
So for this exception to apply,
the issue is whether the
event is legally permissible.
A person may not consent
to a duel for instance,
because dueling has been outlawed.
A person cannot legally consent to
a street fighter or a bar room brawl
even if involves the same kind of conduct
as an MMA match.
Because isn't legal to get
into a gang fight or a bar fight.
But there might be some exceptions
to certain kinds of assault and battery.
Assault is the crime
of putting another person in fear or
apprehension of an unlawful contact.
Battery is the actual application
of that force;
a harmful or offensive contact
with another person's body.
Assault and battery are crimes and torts.
That means a person can be charged
with a crime or sued for
committing assault or battery,
get monetary damages.
Participants in an athletic contest
are deemed to have consented
to certain assaults
and batteries when both the injury
and the conduct that caused it
are reasonably foreseeable hazards
of joint participation
in an athletic contest.
So when is the conduct
reasonably foreseeable?
This isn't always easy to pin down.
NHL hockey player Marty McSorley,
was found guilty of assault with a weapon
after he hit Donald Brashear
in the head with a hockey stick,
when Brashear was skating away from him.
The court rejected McSorley's defense
that NHL players give explicit consent
to the risk of on ice contact.
And that McSorleys's
hit was not an assault.
Hockey fights are a foreseeable risk.
But intentionally striking someone
in the head head with a hockey stick
is considered assault with a deadly weapon
and that's not a foreseeable risk.
Still most jurisdictions have been
very hesitant to prosecute players
even when their behavior
seems to cross a line.
In another hockey case, a New York court
let a player strike
another player in the neck,
slamming him into the goalpost
even after the whistle was blown.
And the court thought that the victim
assumed the risk by participating
in the hockey event
even though it was a league that
didn't allow players to
cross-check each other.
The court thought that
policy considerations
of having quote free
and fierce competition
in athletic events, end quote,
would be severely undermined
if the usual criminal
standards were applied
to athletic competition,
especially ice hockey.
So it's possible
that a court could accept the analogy
and say that if we let
consenting adults engage
in what would otherwise
be criminal behavior
in a sporting event,
then we should absolutely let them consent
to such behavior at a
haunted house as well.
But the court could
also reject that analogy
and say that there are pro-social reasons
why we want to encourage
people participating
in sporting events that simply don't exist
for something as frivolous
as a haunted house.
And that all the safeguards that exist
in a sporting event like
referees and umpires
and the spectators that
actually prevent things
from going too far,
don't exist in the case
of a haunted house.
And it's just too likely
that things are going to go off the rails
for entertainment purposes.
So what's my verdict.
Well, arguably the waiver is legal.
At least for a lot of the things
that it's trying to disclaim
and probably so is the attraction
unless there's a lot
of unknown information
that we don't have.
A few caveats though,
it's notable that McKamey has stopped
the two most legally
questionable practices
which is using minors
and not having a safe word or phrase.
In the past McKamey used
local teenagers as actors
and now he hires only adults.
If a participant absolutely
can't stand it anymore,
they can use a safe phrase
to stop the experience.
At least that's what we think based
on the available evidence.
The Nashville scene has reported
that McKamey now has an
arrangement with the police.
He calls when he's about to give a tour.
Some people think that
none of this is real
and that most of the videos
on the YouTube channel
feature actors not participants.
And having watched a few hours of it,
that's totally plausible,
though definitely not certain.
And frankly this may all
just be a giant ploy for free advertising
because I've done an entire freaking video
on this stupid legal contract.
And McKamey is a master of illusion
and video editing so
nothing is certain here.
There are only two ways to get answers.
One is either sue him
and see what he's got
to say in a deposition
or go through the experience myself.
And I think I'll pass on
both of those options for now.
(laughs)
But believe it or not
this video was not sponsored by McKamey.
I do not recommend that
you go to their website
but at least they were smart enough to
snag mckameymanor.com
because everyone should
own their own website.
When I need a new domain,
I go to hover at hover.com.
Maybe I should go there
and buy up a specialty website like
mckameymanorlower.com or
mckameyclassaction.com
and specialize in representing
all the people who suffered
those cuts, bruises
and other not injuries that they suffered
when they went through McKamey Manor.
Hover is the best place on the internet
to get yourself a domain name in part
because they have over
400 domain extensions
to choose from.
Ranging from .com, .io,
.me to .ninja and .pizza.
You can even get crazy things like
.democrat or .republican if you wanted to.
One of the great things about hover
is that they have lots of domains
that you wouldn't normally think about.
For example, I got legaleagle.tv.
I haven't put up a website yet
but at least it's ready to go
when I figure out what I wanna do with it.
Though I did set up legaleagleprep.com
for helping law students.
And I highly recommend that everyone go
and get their name.com
or the name of their business
before it's gone.
It's super easy to buy a domain on hover.
There are no annoying up sales,
no annoying popups.
And if you have an account like I do,
you can get another domain
in less than 30 seconds.
Or just check to see
if the website of your
dreams is available.
And once you've got your domain,
hover has tools for easily setting up
professional email addresses.
Even if you don't set up the website,
you can still create a professional email.
Because you never wanna be that lawyer
that uses an AOL or
earth like email address.
Don't be like Stephen Biss.
And you can use their
great connect feature
to easily hook up that domain to
a website builder like
Squarespace, Wix or Shopify.
Of course the best part is
that if you go to hover.com/legaleagle
which we'll find in the
description down below
you'll get 10% off your
first domain purchase.
Again, just go to hover.com/legaleagle
or click the link in the description
to get 10% off your first domain.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Should McKamey Manor be allowed to operate
because consenting
adults are gonna consent
or should it be shut down?
Leave your objections in the comments.
And check out this playlist over here
with all of my other legal reactions
as well as my analysis
of all the crazy things
that you'll find on Reddit
and the rest of the internet
from a legal perspective.
So click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.